this was our Vietnam October 31st it was
us against the world we was going to get
them baby snicker and we'd all be on the
back of moms car with the tailgate down
and she's rolling and we're on the back
of mom would roll up by the yard and we
would run and jump off that tailgate
into the yard as that car was going just
like I've been right out the back of a
c-130 man shout out to all of our
servicemen and women just tumble roll
into the yard lose half your [__]
candy in the roll whatever odd word is
anything your sister would come off with
the last minute she only 2 years old and
then it was just every step you could
get through the dark grass to get up to
that front door and the mom is right
there and she got the big bowl and she's
dressed up like a little cat and man you
hope that snicker was in there god I
loved Halloween I'm just thinking about
how spooky it's getting in the world
because it's Halloween time you know
it's Halloween man I mean I used to love
do you remember how remember how much
fun you had Halloween what are you gonna
be what are you gonna be for like a
couple of weeks when you were in like
elementary school middle school what are
you gonna be what are you gonna be I'm
gonna be a princess I'm gonna be a coal
miner I'm gonna be a firefighter
and the costume used to be way more
normal weight like Oh Daniel is a bat oh
that's good job Daniel Lawrence is um
he's a coal miner in a wheelchair oh
good job Lawrence Celina
is pregnant Oh oh that's interesting but
way to go Celina thank you guys for
checking out this clip and if you want
to see another clip and you can look at
this clip or this clip either one of
these so did you pick one or he's still
just watching me do this cuz this is
alarming